so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to try and
pull this out as like a secondary form
of notation right so in fact i'll just
prove this as a i'll even write that
this is a secondary proof
sometimes called an auxiliary proof
because just on the side that's what
auxiliary means i want to prove that a
squared minus a plus 1 over a is greater
than or equal to 1. this is what i'm
after okay
now
as i said you can go the calculus
path with this if you want but i'm
interested in showing you different
tools in your toolbox and so what we're
going to do is we're going to kind of go
into drawing some of the tools that we
used from the nature of proof okay so
buckle up let's have a go
i said that one of the classic ways to
deal with inequality right when we
started this question before we you know
really very far into the proof my
mathematical induction is to get
everything onto one side and then prove
that it's positive or negative right and
that's really helpful here because when
you have a look at what you get here a
squared minus a
plus one over a
minus one can i prove that this is
greater than or equal to zero
what you get here is something which
even though it doesn't look like it can
actually be quite nicely factorized you
might say
that doesn't look like it's nice to
factorize at all but if you look closely
it actually works into two very nice
neat pairs right if you just have a look
at this pairing here and this pairing
here hopefully you have noticed like i
have that they are opposite in sign
one's positive one's negative same deal
here and they're off by a factor of a
you've got this is a times bigger than
this
and this is 8 times bigger than this so
this should be some symmetry here you
can recognize so how am i going to
factorize this a few ways to do it but
the most obvious way that i see is to
take out a failure factor of a from the
first pairing so that gives you a minus
1 like so
and then for this one i'm going to take
a factor of 1
over a and that gives you well just be
careful taking 1 over 8 out of this just
leaves you with one
and then when you take one over a out of
this you can prove this to yourself by
expanding obviously you get a right does
that make sense i should say minus a one
over a times minus a the a's cancel
leave you with minus one okay so that
looks really good because you can see
these are just off by a factor of
negative 1. so in fact what i can do is
if i change this into a minus 1 over a
there in the middle that will turn this
binomial over here into a minus one just
reverses its order and now i have
another common factor i've got a minus
one which is in common and then i've got
a minus one over a greater than or equal
to zero
you might say this is no this looks no
better than what i started with okay but
i actually think this is quite nice to
deal with by exhaustion in other words
doing cases right i can prove in the
domain that i'm interested in which is
for a is greater than zero i can prove
quite neatly actually that this
weird expansion here is always going to
be greater than or equal to zero it
falls out actually quite simply right
here's the way that i'm going to do it
i'm going to think about three cases
right case
1 two and three firstly remembering that
a has to be greater than zero
i'm going to prove
that this is going to be true from zero
all the way up to one
now you might say y one why is that
important and the answer is i didn't put
that in the right spot the answer is i
can see that something happens when a
switches over to
past one right
when you go and put in a equals one here
you get one minus one you get zero
it's kind of like a junction point or a
singularity where this thing kind of
changes right so therefore i'm going to
say that's the first case a equals 1 is
the secondary case and then i just have
to look
after a equals 1. right can you see that
when i combine these domains for each of
these cases they comprehensively
exhaustively cover a is greater than
zero you're going from zero up to one
you handle one and then you go beyond
one okay
so there are the domains
then when i think about this i can say
well look at each of the different
factors in turn can we work out what's
happening to a minus 1
can we know what the sign of that is is
going to be positive negative and then
how is it going to combine with a minus
1 over a once i know what's happening to
each of those two terms there i can then
work out what happens to the product
namely this thing here what can i know
about its sign
so this is my roadmap okay what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to
consider
oh this is going to be really messy but
let's see if i can do it reasonably
quickly for you okay
i'm going to consider
each of these different cases
and they're really straightforward to
think about algebraically oh that wasn't
too bad
there you go oh except it's so messy
here we go
sorry i'm a bit of a stickler for these
things there we go i'm happy with that
okay
i've got my table set up and if i think
about what's happening for each of these
what's going to happen for a minus 1
what's going to happen for a
minus 1 over a this is going to be
pretty straightforward to work out all
of my cases okay
so for starters
let's have a look at when
a is between not and 1 okay when a is
between not and 1. so you've got
fractions like aha for third a quarter
right when you take away one from those
because you have got to be less than one
um you're definitely going to get
something negative do you agree with
that right so long as you're between
zero and one when you take away one
you're going to get a negative value
satisfied okay
when you have a look at a minus 1 over a
think about this right
1 over a
has to be bigger than a
does that make sense right if you've got
fractional values in here right like a
half a third a quarter then 1 over a is
going to be
2 3 4. so you're going to get a small
fraction over here and then the
reciprocal of that is going to be larger
right so therefore this is also going to
be negative because you're subtracting a
larger number from a smaller number
right like a half take away two or a
third take away three they're all going
to be negative okay and when you
multiply two negative numbers this is
what we get with our product over here
you get a positive right remember what
i'm asking for i want this to be greater
than or equal to zero and that checks
out
what about the a equals one case well
this is even easier right
when a is equal to one this is just
going to be zero this is also going to
be zero
so therefore their product will be zero
um is that going to be greater than or
equal to zero and the answer is yes it
is because zero is greater than or equal
to zero namely equal to the boundary
case
and then lastly when i have a look at a
is greater than one i've got the reverse
of the original case right so as long as
you're bigger than one a take away one
obviously has to be positive because you
know you've got numbers like two three
four five when you take away one
obviously you're not small enough to get
down to a negative or to zero so that's
going to be positive and same deal here
right you've got a bigger number out the
front and a smaller number because
you're getting that denominator being
larger so it'd be two take away a half
three take away a third they're all
going to be positive and of course when
you multiply two positive numbers you
get another positive right
so that's it for all of my cases
for all cases
a minus 1
times a minus 1
over a is greater than or equal to 0
which means
therefore this is directly connected to
this up here like so right so therefore
i can say that this is going to be true
oopsie daisy this is going to be true
for the particular domain that i was
interested in what i proved
which is a is greater than zero because
those were that's what my um that's what
my three cases covers right um you're
okay between norton one you're okay at
one and you're okay beyond one as well
okay
so that was my secondary proof i can now
return to let's uh let's give this a
name let's call that one and over here
i've got a to the k plus one
one over
a to the k plus one
so therefore i'm going to grab this
copy that
okay so returning to one
i'm almost ready to tie this up in a
nice neat bow i can say
i've got this
and therefore i can say that this is
going to be greater than or equal to
let's give this a name as well this is 2
okay
i can say all of whoops you don't rub
that out all of this is unchanged
but this is being multiplied by
1 from
2. you can see how i'm bringing in this
result over here
right here i'm substituting it for
something that's greater than or equal
to it right
so therefore this is
ie
when you multiply by 1 that doesn't
change this term on the end there
that it so i've just proved the k plus
one step our case rather
from the k step that was my assumption
so i can say as
required
finished
so now finally i can say true
for
a is greater than zero and n is greater
than uh or rather ends a positive
integer i could say um
that's greater than or equal to one by
principle
of mathematical induction
and then i can finally exhale
so what have we learned from this
question in many ways just like every
other proof by mathematical induction
the the skeleton of it is the same the
basic structure we test we assume we
prove but in both the test and the proof
step i mean the assumed step where you
just stated right
in both the test and in the peru step
for k plus one um there are a couple of
curveballs right we pulled out calculus
in the middle of a proof by induction
and that was mainly because of this um
this characteristic of a it wasn't just
n like in in the
in integer land it's pretty unusual to
pull out calculus but it's because of
this a being a real number and it being
you know remaining is an unknown a
variable here that we had to appeal to
calculus to even just do the base case
and then when doing the k plus 1 case
you end up with this unusual result
which we could have applied calculus to
all over again but it was just as useful
i think to
and i would say
um actually easier to deal with because
you don't have to
it doesn't necessitate the solution of a
qb polynomial
you you end up with with dealing with
this by cases which is actually even
though it looks long is a fairly
straightforward way of doing things
which is why it is still a very useful
tool in your mathematical toolbox i
guess what i would suggest is knowing
how to break up this object
into meaningful cases which are these
three over here that does does take a
little practice and i knew that this was
going to be a junction point because of
where this thing switches over sine but
hopefully you can see why my logic holds
so hopefully that makes sense and you'll
be able to have more tools in your
toolbox for approaching questions like
this one once we get there eventually
when you encounter them in the future